SpongeBob SquarePants is an iconic
cartoon that can make us laugh for days
on end it's cast is filled with funny
characters who make their characters
come to life before our eyes let's pull
back the curtain and find out which
brilliant voice actors are responsible
for our favorite bikini bottom dwellers
now let's put a face to some of the most
hilarious SpongeBob SquarePants
characters ever
Carolyn Lawrence as Sandy Cheeks first
on the list is Carolyn Lawrence the
highly gifted voice actress who's
responsible for many of our favorite
animated characters I'm Carolyn Lawrence
and I place the empty cheeks Carolyn is
always happy and excited making her the
perfect fit for Sandy Cheeks if there's
one thing that Carolyn loves about her
character is that she's 100% random
after all it isn't common for Land
critters to live in bikini bottom
who's just normal and sweet that's not
fun you want to play somebody who's
crazy sandy when it comes to voice
acting Carolyn is basically a genius
which is why she's managed to stay
afloat in the industry for nearly 30
years
although sandy is her most prominent
role she's also known for playing Cindy
vortex from The Adventures of Jimmy
Neutron and Ashley Graham from Resident
Evil 4 so how did Carolyn get so into
the business well let's just say that
the business found her if I thought that
I'd be working in animation or voicing I
didn't even have a reference point these
awesome clips were brought to us by the
Issy animation ultra channel we couldn't
imagine anyone other than Carolyn
voicing the eccentric Sandy Cheeks isn't
she just hilarious
Bob Joel's as man ray next on the list
is the one and only Bob Dole's
this acclaimed actor has been lending
his voice to hysterical characters ever
since the late 80s and many of his fans
were shocked to find out that he played
Man Ray on Sponge Bob Squarepants
although Man Ray doesn't show his face
in every single episode you know you're
in for a treat whenever he surfaces
here's a beloved scene from season two
episode 31 that many of us still can't
get over it is yours I am trying to be a
good person and return it to you one
look at Bob's portfolio is all you need
to know that he's a big shot but hey
even Big Shots have to start somewhere
and my first job for Disney was doing
the voice of sneezy here's a clip of Bob
getting into character in case you need
to freshen up on your snow white dwarves
it was posted by the mouse info channel
[Music]
if you're an anime fan you'll be happy
to know that Bob also plays Boonton from
the epic TV series Naruto Syrena urban
as old lady Serina Arwen is a renowned
voice actress you can basically mimic
anyone's voice her range is impressive
which is what makes her such an
important addition to the Spongebob cast
she plays a handful of characters in
this cartoon her most popular one being
old lady in season 3 episode 12 we got
to see how distinctive Serena's voice
could truly become Serena's been a part
of the cast ever since its first episode
aired in 1999
she's voiced babies Girl Scouts police
officers customers and whatever random
characters are thrown her away Serena is
in popular demand which is why she also
voices characters like dr. Quinzel and
Batman versus two-face and Tina towel in
pig goat banana cricket but there's one
character you might recognize over all
others you have one hour to complete
your test eyes on your own paper
[Music]
that's right Serena also is responsible
for voicing dr. J and mrs. DiMartino
from the loud house we don't know about
you but we can't imagine what SpongeBob
SquarePants would be like without
Serena's influence Thomas F Wilson as
cop number two Thomas Wilson might have
gotten his big break by acting in front
of the camera but that's never stopped
him from lending his voice to a cartoon
character or two Tom's been a valuable
member of the Spongebob squad since 2001
and he's known for playing cop number
two however he also plays Tony fast sing
key mutton chop strangler and many other
little characters we're looking for the
maniac have you seen Tom reach star
status when he laid the role of Biff
Tannen in 1985's Back to the Future and
unsurprisingly he managed to stay in the
spotlight ever since Tom's voice acting
is on point which is why he's also
responsible for characters like bucket
from Dragons riders of Berk cat man from
adventure time and Matt bluestone from
gargoyles despite his enormous portfolio
Tom's following isn't what it ought to
be who are you and then some people like
oh my god this interview was brought to
us by ABC's Action News are you guys
shocked to find out that Sponge Bob has
been hosting Big Time stars like Tom
Wilson because we sure are Mary Jo
Catlett as mrs. puff Mary Jo Catlett is
a famous actress who's been pumping out
hit after hit since the mid 60s she's
appeared in popular sitcoms like Saved
by the Bell General Hospital and the
Hardy Boys however she's also an
incredible voice actress who you
probably know all too well
Mary Jo has been voicing mrs. cough
since the cartoon first aired in 1999
and we wouldn't want it any other way in
season 4 episode 9 we got to see how
much mrs. puff really valued her job and
seeing her get fired was more than a
little heartbreaking Mary Jo might be 80
years old but she's nowhere close to
retiring in fact she's recently made
appearances and hit TV shows like two
Broke Girls Glee and
Modern Family did you guys know that
Mary Jo is also a successful Broadway
actress here's a clip from the play The
Pajama game all in all it's safe to say
that Mary Jo is as talented as they come
we love you mrs. puff Tim Conway as
barnacleboy is there anyone more amazing
than Tim Conway we highly doubt it this
acclaimed actor has been at the top of
the chart since the mid 60s
and he's not done yet most of us know
him for his work on SpongeBob
SquarePants but too many he's much more
than just Barnacle Boy I am crossing
over to the dark side tim has often been
referred to as the master of comedy and
it isn't too hard to see why after all
the guys are riot in fact the actor had
his very own talk show in the early 70s
which was named the Tim Conway show his
portfolio is impressive to say the least
which is why many people were surprised
to find out that he's the one and only
Barnacle Boy although Tim usually enjoys
being in front of the camera he's taken
a liking to voice acting over the last
few decades
he played mulch in Dragons riders of
Berk where he managed to nail a Viking
accent as though it were nothing we
thought suppers er kurz had hit the nice
bird so we came in to help Jill Talley
as Karen next up is Jill Talley the
talented voice actress who's known for
voicing Karen on SpongeBob she's been a
proud contributor to the show since 1999
and she's managed to appear in one
hundred and twenty-six episodes although
she's majorly known for portraying Karen
she also lends her voice to random
characters whenever need be but do you
even care all you ever do is make
let's keep Karen's voices super
versatile which is why she's also a
member of the adventuretime squad
she's been voicing characters like
gridface princess mother bird gumdrop
daughter and many others since 2012
during a mini interview with real films
Tom Kenny and Jill revealed a little
secret that shocked many of their
viewers and the fourth thing was way if
you're gonna be married to somebody it's
good to be married to your wife that's
right guys Sponge Bob and Karen are
married in real life can you believe
that Jill just finished doing the voice
acting for 2020s upcoming film Rocko's
Modern Life static cling the actress
will be portraying nosy heads we can't
wait to see her bring the character to
life Ernest Borgnine as mermaidman the
late Ernest Borgnine is a legend however
he was before our time which is why mini
Sponge Bob fans won't recognize his name
at first but once we get the ball
rolling you won't be able to get this
oscar-winning actor out of your head
Ernest was responsible for voicing
Mermaid Man a character who had long
since turned senile after a life of fame
[Music]
Ernest portfolio dates all the way back
to the early 50s proving that the man
had a long successful career in show
business he's been known for his leading
roles in movies like Marty and the Wild
Bunch so when he chose to join the
Spongebob Squarepants cast everyone was
instantly on board in a youtube clip
posted by foundation interviews ernest
explains how he managed to stay relevant
in the 21st century this incredible
actor was one of the most talented
people who ever stepped foot in
Hollywood and he won't be forgotten mr.
Lawrence as plankton mr. Lawrence is the
evil mastermind behind the beloved
spongebob character plankton his voice
is deep and villainous making him the
perfect actor for the job
mr. Lawrence has had the pleasure of
voicing many popular characters which is
why his portfolio isn't as jam-packed as
other voice actors his age after all
when it comes to mr. Lawrence he values
quality over quantity in a clip that was
posted
Robert didn't a we get to see mr.
Lawrence slip into character right
before our eyes the hilarious actor is
known for getting a little carried away
while in the heat of the moment and he
has this in common with plankton don't
come to the Chum Bucket it's horrible
the celebrity is known for playing
Dilbert turtle in Rocko's Modern Life
Benjy from Rugrats and Rafi oh and
helmets from mighty magic words did you
know that mr. Lawrence is responsible
for more than one spongebob character
well and equip posted by the same
youtuber we get to see the extent of his
talents hey spongebob
wanna lift some weights sara paxton as
kid fish now this one might come as a
surprise but the gorgeous sara paxton is
also involved in the making of SpongeBob
SquarePants
in fact she's been a contributor since
1999
Sarah landed the gig when she was only
11 years old and her girly and squeaky
voice came in handy from the get-go gee
thanks mr. Krabs I thought you were a
cheap old tightwad Sarah might not have
her own character but she's used to
voicing whichever extras come her way
she's a popular actress who tends to
prefer being in front of the camera but
she's a huge spongebob fan and she's
dedicated to her roles like no other you
might recognize Sarah from big-time
movies like aquamarine the gamekeepers
and The Last House on the Left while she
has yet to win a big award we are
certain that her time will come in a
clip posted by a youtube channel Gloria
zero zero zero four we get to see a
young Sarah clocking in some serious
studio time look a haunted mattress
although many spongebob characters are
currently filming for the show's third
movie Sarah will not be joining the cast
which is a total bummer Clancy Brown as
mr. Krabs is there anyone as successful
as Clancy Brown when it comes to voice
acting we highly doubt it in fact
Clancy's basically the cream of the crop
he's known for spending as much time in
front of the camera as he does in the
studio so basically he pursues any role
that he can relate to his dark voice of
maniacal laugh
making the perfect bad guy but he's not
known for playing a villainous role on
SpongeBob SquarePants nope he's known
for playing mr. Krabs here's a clip of
Clancy rehearsing his lines it was
posted by the movie extras YouTube
channel Clancy is used to playing
villains which is why he was cast as Lex
Luthor in 2013's Lego Batman the movie
in a clip posted by Jay shockblast
Clancy explains why playing evil
characters is so much fun but it's
really not fun to play a good guy
because we did there is a part where we
play a good guy
all in all few people could give Clancy
a run for his money and that's the way
he likes it carlos alazraqui as surfer
carlos alazraqui is one of the best
voice actors we can think of so
naturally it's pretty fitting to find
him amongst the spongebob cast after all
the show's producers made it a point to
only include the best in the industry
Carlos joined the production at the very
beginning and he's lent his voice to
countless characters however he's most
known for portraying surfer dude see
what I mean Carlos isn't your everyday
average voice actor and this is due to
his ever-expanding portfolio and ability
to generate new voices on demand just
check out this video reel that Carlos
posted on his YouTube channel and see
for yourself
although he may not have a prominent
role on SpongeBob SquarePants he still
manages to keep himself busy bill Fagor
back as Patrick Starr bill Fagor back is
a brilliant actor who also has a deep
dark secret
he's responsible for Patrick Starr's
mindless voice Phil's both an actor and
voice artists making him a staple in the
industry he plays Marshall Eriksen's
father in How I Met Your Mother and King
Joey in all hail King Julien but his
biggest and favorite role will always be
the one of Patrick while being
interviewed by Scott Carney bill came
clean about his feelings towards plain
everyone's favorite starfish are you
kidding this is the greatest thing that
could possibly bills a sweet guy he'll
go out of his way for his fans during a
Comic Con show and Alamo City bill gave
a fan a quick shout out using Patrick's
voice
nations of my mind are an enigma this
video was brought to us by youtuber JT
Rodger Bumpass as Squidward Tentacles
Rodger Bumpass is the voice actor who
fills Squidward's gills with its cynical
tone he's been a dedicated voice artist
since the late 70s and we couldn't
imagine anyone else voicing the grumpy
Squidward we all know and love Rodgers
also well known for playing dr. light in
the hit TV series Teen Titans here's a
clip of Roger getting into character
during San Diego's comic-con this video
was posted by the Nickelodeon YouTube
channel just when I thought they
couldn't get any stupider although
Squidward and Roger might be two birds
of a feather they don't seem to like
each other very much
third time's a charm
this hilarious clip was also brought to
us by Nickelodeon Lorri Allen as pearl
Krabs pearl Krabs is known for two
things
crying her eyes out and crying her heart
out so basically the Bikini Bottom
dweller is a big fat crybaby
she's voiced by actress and Lorri Allen
who also plays Diane Simmons in Family
Guy you're really gonna use hypnosis to
get rid of them
Lori has a nasally voice that perfectly
encompasses her characters whiny ways
but oddly enough Laurie wasn't always
interested in being a voice artist it's
something that she got into after
becoming an actress in a clip posted by
a voiceover body shop we find out what
said Sponge Bob apart from other
productions I'm hilarious I did The
Groundlings in Newark I'm just gonna go
right into animation on my friend set me
down I was like
although learning a new trade wasn't
easy we're happy that Laurie got the job
done Tom Kenny as Sponge Bob Squarepants
without the brilliant Tom Kenny it's
safe to say that there'd be no spongebob
this comic can alter his voice and
create SpongeBob's ridiculous laugh with
ease and for this we are eternally
grateful Tom is also a member of the
Adventure Time squad where he portrays
the Ice King Gunther and starchy his
voice knows no limits which is why he's
the king when it comes to voice acting
here's a clip of Tom in the studio he
was posted by the scream slam YouTube
channel I guess this means the secret
formula is safe forever right mr. Krabs
it's no secret that Tom is incredibly
talented but did you know that he's
responsible for more than one spongebob
character this clip was supposed to buy
atom jammer and it's showcases Tom
portraying a handful of his prized
characters
I do the French narrator this is two
hours later before you go make sure to
tell us which spongebob character is
your favorites in the comments below and
that's a wrap thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]